que henri sterdyniak économiste à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques et membre des économistes
atterrés
bonsoir on y sert lignac merci d'être
avec nous excessif inique ça
inacceptable disproportionnée à les
oppositions évidemment sont montés au
créneau pour dénoncer ces suppressions
de postes
est-ce que clairement selon vous on
aurait pu les éviter vu le contexte on a
une situation qui est tragique si l'on
peut dire c'est que on a un secteur
économique l'aviation l'aéronautique qui
va subir très fort ralentissement et
même une décrue de son activité à la
suite de la crise sanitaire bien sûr le
tourisme va reprendre un choc important
le il ya des mesures qui sont prises
pour éviter la propagation de la
pandémie qui nuisent au transport aérien
les préoccupations écologiques font que
on dit aux gens ne prenaient plus
l'avion prenez le train
tout ça fait que l'activité d'air france
et de nombreuses autres compagnies
aériennes ralenti du coup ils se
retrouvent avec suffisamment et même
trop d'action est naturellement bas ça
les amène à supprimer annuler des
commandes chez airbus et chez boeing est
donc naturellement ça crée un problème
de sureffectifs et il est très difficile
de régler un problème de sureffectifs
autrement que en réduisant les emplois
alors certains demande même au
gouvernement d'empêcher un cc
licenciement d'ailleurs bruno le maire
s'est exprimé là dessus il n'est
vraiment pas chaud pour des
licenciements contraints est-ce qu'on
peut carrément les interdire c'est
possible
le problème c'est si on interdit les en
ciment que fait-on des sureffectifs est
ce que on va conserver des gens en
disant ma voilà en fait on n'a rien à
vous faire faire donc c'est pas une
solution la solution c'est l'arc on
version c'est à dire de dire des gens
qui pensaient travailler dans
l'aéronautique et va il faut qu'ils
travaillent dans d'autres métiers qui
deviennent enseignants qui deviennent
qui se dit qu'ils se lancent dans le btp
ou dans ou dans le soin à la personne
effectivement c'est tragique mais on
peut pas à la fois dire il faut réduire
des vols qui sont extrêmement coûteux en
termes écologiques et maintenir et
maintenir l'emploi donc le le problème
c'est il faut organiser la reconversion
et mais j'imagine voilà quelqu'un par
exemple un pilote qui a fait des études
qui a galéré entre guillemets pour en
arriver là vous lui dites bâle et être
enseignant our vous reconvertir dans le
bâtiment sachant que c'est pas des
métiers non plus très simple quand on
voit la colère sociale
aujourd'hui les salaires à ses bad et
des professeurs c'est extrêmement
difficile alors l'état en plus injecter
plusieurs milliards dans le secteur
aéronautique on peut s'interroger
clairement pourquoi ces plans d'une
telle ampleur alors que l'état a injecté
des milliards 7 milliards par exemple
ces 7 milliards sont utiles nécessaires
pour qu'effectivement les entreprises
restructurent qu'elle s'adapte à la
transition écologique
on va lancer des recherches pour avoir
des avions qui sont beaux qu'ils sont
beaucoup moins polluant qui émettent
moins de gaz à effet de serre on se
retrouve quand même devant une période
très difficile où ces avions écologique
n'existe pas et où on dit aux gens et
éviter au maximum de prendre l'avion et
donc naturellement ça veut dire que il
ya un problème de sureffectifs
est ce qu'on peut reprocher
effectivement à l'état ou à aux
entreprises c'est de ne pas avoir
anticipé effectivement
ralentissement de l'activité
aéronautique un faut se souvenir qu'il
ya six mois
on voulait se poser la question de du
nouvel aéroport à nantes se posait la
question de vendre un prix extrêmement
élevé aéroports de paris et on prenait
pas prenez pas en compte le fait qu'il
va y avoir transition écologique
c'est-à-dire que secteur par secteur il
faut réfléchir dans quelle mesure mon
secteur est un secteur d'avenir et 6,6
un secteur d'avenir
il faut embaucher il faut former si
c'est un secteur qui doit réduire la
voilure naturellement la question se
pose la question se pose différemment a
effectivement on peut réduire le coût
seul le coût social en disant on va
faire du tu travailles à à temps partiel
on va faire des des congés sabbatiques
mais foncièrement il va falloir d'une
façon du l'autre diminuer l'emploi et il
faut reconvertir de manière la plus
sociale possible avec des prestations
qui permettent de faire le jeu qui
permettent de maintenir un certain
niveau de vie fort convertir une partie
des effectifs aller à tamponner le taux
de chômage en france en tout cas merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france merci à vous